calling in right now uh he's uh I love
everything that he does he's got a great
call on uh the LCS last night the
Dodgers advancing he and Joe Buck are
going to be calling the World Series on
FOX starting tomorrow night he is none
other than Hall of Famer John Smoltz how
you doing John I'm doing good thanks for
having me of course so I mean some
nerve-wracking times for the Dodgers but
they have just got some timely hitters
and then that uh do we even call him a
kid in right field I mean do we call all
that I mean what is it like seeing that
in person that way that Mookie Betts
plays that
position yeah it's it's incredible you
know I said you know the game is what it
is as far as uh the design philosophy of
how you play defense but the one thing
you can say is outfielders you get a
chance to see their athleticism they're
not playing in a shift they're not
bunched together they individually carry
uh the distance uh that they can they
can cover and you know when you have the
talent and the defense sense that the
Dodgers have it speaks for itself
Bellinger of course in first first of
the greatest catches I've ever seen
against the Padres under the
circumstances there were so many twists
in the Padre series and the brav series
that could easily led the Dodgers out
and defensively they turned the series
around before they were able to turn it
around offensively and look mukie B bets
is a special special talent and like I
said if you're an infielder with a great
talent you don't always get to see them
they may be in a position where they
don't normally play 80% of the time
they're in the shift so you can't really
see the giftedness that um some of these
guys have and we got to see it at full
display with mookie bets and bell and
you know and then Will Smith obviously
now added to a mix that already has
Justin Turner and stars all over the map
for the LA Dodgers at who are now back
in the World Series before we move on to
that uh I do want to give you the floor
on the Braves and the organization with
with which you're most closely
associated from your Hall of Fame
playing days and and what they were able
to do and almost pull off yeah they
almost pulled off the perfect trifecta
and what I mean by that is they they did
not have the full arsenal that would
take you deep into the World Series if
they had to play a lot of deep Series so
they swept their first two games which
was incredible against the Cincinnati
Reds and one of the most epic first
games I've ever seen in 13 Innings and
then they took care of the Marlins in
three straight and it looked like the
formula was going to work for the
Dodgers they were up 3-1 no one saw it
coming and then they were going to have
the ability to try and finish it off and
win one game unfortunately for the
Braves they had some
opportunistic they had some
opportunities they just didn't come
through they had Bases Loaded nobody out
against bu um that was a big missplay
and then they had some bad Miss base
running so from a from a long-term
scenario they're set up very well they
got some great experience that are young
player Young pitchers but it it's it
never feels good or tastes good when you
lose but at the end of the day when we
were looking at this series going seven
it heavily favored the Dodgers um but
what the Dodgers were able to do you
just got to give them credit for
executing because their backs they had a
lot of pressure on them and I've said
all along they've answered the call
every single time I don't think they
want to put themselves in another
situation like this previous S Series
but uh it ended up being an epic game
seven the series was unpredictable and
had twists that you couldn't you know
after it was two games to none The
Narrative was the Dodgers are in trouble
then the Dodgers win a blowout the
Braves are done and then the Braves win
they're up three to one the Dodgers are
in trouble and then of course you know
the rest is U Been documented John
Smoltz here on the Rich Eisen show so do
you think that uh they're now I mean
normally the Dodgers have been in the
World Series before you can't even say
they're playing with with house money
certainly since one of the pitches
they're going to see is one of the
pitchers that that did him in uh in the
World Series in a game seven because
Charlie Morton's on that raised team how
do you think this team is entering
mentally uh a World
Series think they're in the best place
they've ever been and the reason I say
that is uh you you it is very this was
going to be the most difficult
championship for any team to win and uh
for the obvious all the things they're
going through now yes the year was
shorter and people are going to point to
that but the but the journey was harder
and so when you've got all this baggage
that they've had to deal with the
Dodgers and you're having to answer the
call time and time again this has become
a special year for them as a group
because of all the things I just said
and they have the component if they
don't trick it up too much they have the
the depth and the roster to beat anybody
now what the Rays provide isn't
unbelievable challenge for anybody when
you think about shortening the game you
better have the lead you better find a
way by the sixth inning to get a lead
against this team and you I think the
Dodgers if they can stay patient no
matter what the scenario is they have
the starting pitching um to get them
deep into a into a series the thing I
think is going to be the biggest now the
Rays have overcome this so far they've
had a five-game series against the the
Yankees and a seven game series that may
shouldn't have happened against the the
Astros they've overcome their swing and
Miss offense it's going to be difficult
to keep doing that but if they find a
way to keep winning their one-run games
and and hit homers they basically only
score by hitting homers then they've got
a legitimate chance to knock off the
Dodgers but I really think this series
comes down to the team that puts the
ball in play more is going to win what
do you mean by Trick it up John I think
I I I think I could guess but I want uh
I want you to put more words on that do
you mean by sometimes when you have as
many weapons as a team does you find
yourself trying to use those weapons in
so many situations that it can come to
backfire you know it can start diluting
that that depth and and and I know that
there's a lot of information there and
and there's the anxiety to win a game
when you have it there but using guys in
in in positions or situations and then
asking him to do something else later is
very difficult on young pitching and so
you know the whole idea of seven days in
a row was going to be that the depth
wins out you got five starters and the
Dodgers went in a kind of a different
direction they use some of their
starters in relief then they asked them
to start and and that's what I kind of
mean if if if it comes down to that and
I know we got our two off days back so
you can utilize guys in different
ways um it it it feels great it looks
great if it works it starts becoming a
little more scratchy your head head if
it doesn't and and that's kind of what I
mean by that I think that that it's real
easy to throw out
Kershaw buer then you got other studs
like May and gelin and and Urus I love
Urus I think he's I think he's got the
potential to be a lockdown starter for
the rest of his career but we he's been
used out of the pen he's had valuable
ACC access access out of the pen and
that's kind of what I mean you know the
the information is great
but what Dave Roberts did at the end of
that game was let his eyes see what this
young kid was doing goodness finish the
game thank goodness you don't see that
too often right John you don't see uh
gut I mean that was gut that was gut
like the Dave Roberts's gut told him to
just let this kid finish it out and not
go with the button push just because
it's the ninth inning and go to his
closer who had put together some
performances to get his confidence back
but three perfect Innings to close out
the game that's it now they're in the
World Series that's my point so you can
go over a football script and how you
want scenario a b c d and e to work and
sometimes it does but you got to you
gotta adjust on the Fly and I think they
they they did that you know there's so
much pressure on Dave Roberts and the
and the and the
Dodgers because of the past um I don't
even like call failures but last of
execution and you know the narrative was
getting stronger and stronger the more
this series played out and so for that
to finish the way it did there's a
collective sigh of relief that I think
now they can play This World Series a
little bit more straight up if you will
and and I think that would be that would
serve them well their offense was
dormant early and then they woke up
their offense is what makes them so
unique and they walk they they just
grind out at back and at the at the end
of the day they just they won the Battle
of the intangibles that don't measure in
the metrics of you know analytics they
won that battle whether it was base
running defense taking a walk those
little things is what they did better
and so uh before I let you go let's talk
a little bit of rays here um I guess as
you point out you better have a you
better have a lead right uh on this team
because of how many fire hoses come out
of that pen and uh and and it's just
amazing you know so much conversation
even dick vitel was going nuts on
Twitter uh during the ACL the during
game seven when Charlie Morton is
removed uh after five and 2/3 uh he's
given up two hits he doesn't even have a
pitch count uh nearing 70 and they just
like this is what they do I I I guess
that's what they do right yeah and
that's my point I mean it again on paper
just from
um the organization utilizes their
assets as good as anybody there's no
doubt about that I mean if you're a if
you're a GM and you want to make you
know the bravs call you to make a trade
you hang up as fast as you can on them
because they make All the Right Moves
lately and they they've processed what
there's no denying that but I think for
a regular season there are a lot of
value in in what they do and of course
it's been a shorter season I think there
are times though when the postseason
could come around to your point
exactly those are the head scratchers
they worked it worked out but those are
the things you go okay this is what they
are and this is what they do and they've
done they're going to do it till the end
of the season I get it um so that'll be
the interesting challenge now you know
come postseason one you're facing a
mirror image kind of yourself you got
two teams that really Mirror Image but
it is definitely going to be from the
sixth inning on 100 miles an hour coming
out of the pen
and the ability for them to uh mix and
match they have the unique right-handed
relever the unique left hand they have
every style angle they create deception
in different ways and they have gone out
and sought it and they've really
perfected the ability to use all their
pieces I'm sitting here today all day
today and all day tomorrow just catching
up on the all the weapons they have
because it's not like the Dodgers they
throw out their eight or nine guys and
they're going to they're going to
they're going to live with those
the the Rays can do a lot of things you
know we're here on the anniversary of
Reggie hitting three home runs against
the Dodgers to win the World Series uh
1977 it's the anniversary on this day in
1977 that that happened and we you know
we've seen uh you know Springer done it
since and and um we'll we'll we'll see
that again will we ever see like Jack
mors again will we ever see somebody
saying okay I'll take the ball in the
10th will that person even be allowed to
go through the third time in the order
you know no you know they always say in
sports and in life the pendulum always
swings too far and then eventually comes
back I think it'll come back but but if
the if the certain philosophies are
allowed or the reward system is there
for you if they tell you as a pitcher
look just get after it in the first
inning go until your tank gets empty
that's what you're going to do you're
not going to say nah n let me let me do
it a different way the organization is
basically telling the players and how
they want the the the script to get
written and I think that the only way to
answer your question fairly that we get
closer or back to a a role that has
certain expectations that are different
is the injury rate is continuing to grow
that you can't fulfill that position
anymore there was some danger here in
this format that teams and we saw it had
no ability to throw a starter out there
for any length it was Johnny Bullpen
almost every game and I think that's
going to be difficult to to explain over
162 yet alone in this format think about
we didn't even have that many games so
you would think everyone would be
fresher that that there just weren't
many teams that had starters healthy
enough or equipped to do that so the the
short answer is no we won't see that
anytime soon a bummer hey John always
great I love you and Joe you're just
such a great listen um and and also
Davis too I think he's terrific also uh
just great stuff out of you and the rest
of the Fox Sports crew and I look
forward to the World Series I'll be out
there watching I appreciate it thanks
let's let's chat again soon that's John
Smoltz